look i'm still on the internet you
haven't gotten rid of me i'm still here
and i'm in my kitchen where the
patriarchy believes i should be
but more importantly i'm choosing to be
right now
cute welcoming way to start
oh no also i'm wearing a beanie inside
because my roots have decided to express
themselves
independently of what i want for them
and also because it feels like a nice
little weighted blanket on my very
anxious cranium hi my name is grace
helping you do not know now you know
your life is different now welcome to
another cooking video i've cleaned my
kitchen solely for the purposes of
impressing you so welcome to the time of
the day where the sun shifts and
lighting might change throughout this
but everyone like lighting should change
we don't need to get so introspective so
early on what are we making today
tilapia with scallion sriracha pesto
that seems like flavor profiles
from a variety of areas of the world and
i'm very excited i'm mostly excited
because i've already made this dish in
the last week and i loved it so i'm
making it again full disclosure i did
make this dish a little compromised um
couldn't believe that i made the dish
and two couldn't believe how delicious
it was so i'm very curious to see if
it's equally as delicious now before we
get into making the meal like all good
chefs we should first address some
talking points points in which i need to
talk to you about hellofresh if you
don't know is america's number one meal
kit and you should know this by now
because i just say it all the time on
the internet constantly it's the only
meal kit i use and it
feeds me and eating is number one and i
live in america it just all adds up
maintain your goals and take control of
your food choices with hellofresh they
have so many different recipe options
that you can really get out of your
recipe rut i see you over there in that
rut it doesn't look comfortable perhaps
you'd like to join me over here we're
rutles or rutless rut ro and if you
don't enjoy cooking because it takes up
too much time don't worry they have
quick and easy meal options that take 20
minutes you got 20 minutes maybe you
could stop yanking it for a second and
then spend some time
stirring it and obviously because
everything comes pre-portioned for you
in these recipes you are saving on food
waste save waste no ruts less wanking
you're on your way to being a very
functional adult person i'd like to get
on that train to functional adult town
let's start making this as always
everything you need for a hello fresh
recipe comes in this handy dandy brown
paper bag
with no eggs that fell so gently and
also
like sadly there was a sadness to the
end of that are you okay bud hey there
you go buck up you're gonna become
something great i just know it you and
me i know you don't trust me yet but i
trust me and that's um
oh where's the fish look at this
gray cold slimy that's how i feel
sometimes
wow magicians pull rabbits out of hats
but can they make a meal with them ooh
probably could if they were on alone wow
what a spin-off magicians that are put
into the wilderness and forced to live
off the land does anyone out there work
at discovery i've got a pitch for you
i just said it rewind this video and
tell me what you think oh
just like my feelings all the
ingredients come completely
compartmentalized we are going to wash
and dry all produce we are going to peel
and mince or grate the ginger we're
going down to the lower level where the
sharp things are ah yes what were you
doing down there watching pornography
come upstairs with your mother and have
dinner we have personified our kitchen
appliances that's
the sign of functional adult do you know
why they call it mints
because it's the sound the knife makes
when you
perform the activity
yeah but you didn't know that and you
should probably forget it because that's
false now we are going to finally chop
our scallions this is like if shrek
wanted hair extensions the best part
about this brown paper bag it doubles as
trash who doesn't these days this comes
with two packs of scallions i assume
that we need all of those but
i don't love scallions so i might just
use one
is that crazy it might be a little crazy
we're gonna half our lemon and we're
gonna cut
one half into wedges i'm giving this
half of a lemon a wedgie now we begin
cooking the rice we are going to heat a
drizzle of oil in a small pot and we're
going to add a tablespoon of our ginger
and we're going to stir until fragrant
and then we're going to add three
quarters a cup of water pinch of salt
put our rice in boil it
reduce heat to low cover let sit for 15
to 18 minutes got that tablespoon of
ginger that seems like a tablespoon of
ginger hands
are body spoons rice goes in
teeth are just mouth knives okay while
that comes to a boil we're gonna move on
to step three we're gonna make our
scallion pesto okay so in a medium bowl
i don't want any good balls or bad bowls
i want a medium bowl you seem
average to your core we're going to add
our scallions sesame oil oh i love
sesame oil it smells nice the rice is
boiling oh gosh now we turn this down to
low cover and let that do its thing half
the sesame seeds i'm sorry i have to
separate some of you guys from the other
ones you'll rejoin in
the very chaotic environment of my
bowels you'll love it there a tablespoon
of olive oil a teaspoon of the ginger a
teaspoon of sugar i have splenda i'm
gonna use splenda i'm making a choice
i'm doing a decision and i'm not looking
back oops i look back and juice from
half the lemon i guess be careful of
seeds or keep them in if you like a
little surprising crunch and you like to
play the game is that a seed or my molar
breaking i see you in there trying to
hang out you bad boys get out of there
and sriracha to taste we mix it up and
we season with salt and pepper
just like that we got scallion sriracha
pesto oh this smells so great it brings
me back
to five days ago when i ate this rice is
going we got our sriracha um
scallion pesto now on to the fish pat
this dry and generously season all over
with salt and pepper and then we're
gonna put it into this pan with olive
oil and cook it that's pretty
straightforward wow what a reveal
you guys feel like kidneys
i've never felt a kidney but you can
assume certain things season these
friends with salt and pepper one of
these is way bigger than the other but
it's not about the size
well it is actually in cooking there's
something about making fish that just
makes me feel
so fancy i think because it's like an
option at weddings
that it feels like it's just an elevated
food so this is something you can make
for like a date or like
a wedding if you're making dinner for a
wedding cook the tilapia
a little sizzle four to six minutes per
side i'm making this true to time i also
like to immediately wash off the counter
where i put raw
food items so that i don't forget and
then it just like steeps in hot tip guys
it's like i've never cleaned before four
to six minutes per side i've not been
paying attention to the clock
that's fine and then we're left here
with all of this excellent listen to
that
cooking oh i just got a little whiff of
fish a little fish with maybe that's
what i would call my perfume a little
whiff of fish anyone out there work in
the
cologne industry oh that's fish baby oh
that's a big boy so while the fish
finishes cooking and the rice finishes
cooking we take this bag of green beans
and we poke some holes in it and we put
it in the microwave for one to two
minutes and then we put it in a bowl
with butter and salt and pepper
this is cooking this is going into the
microwave for one to two minutes and
we'll need a bowl for that when it comes
out and we'll need some butter okay
we'll put this butter
in here be like a sneak attack the green
beans are just going to be placed in a
regular old empty bowl ah [ __ ]
that's butter in there hello
guess what you're just going in a
regular old bowl
nothing to freak out about psych there's
butter in there [ __ ] or put
some salt and pepper in with these green
bands do you like that fish is done rice
is basically done now it's time to plate
this all up i'm gonna use the big fish
see how they do it oh the fish was
supposed to go okay i could have done
this better the plate looks a little
greasy but
it's a sign of good health
[Music]
this is how they look in their profile
picture
and this is how they show up and you're
like yeah i will take this in sickness
and in health oh my gosh i did this
quickly too the other incredible thing
about this meal other than this meal
itself is that i have an offer for you
i don't just reap the rewards of making
this right now you can too if you are
interested you can go to hellofresh.com
and use the code hellbig16 for up to 16
free meals and three
surprise gifts it really is like a
wedding once again that offer is go to
hellofresh.com use the code hellbig16
for 16 free meals and three surprise
gifts i hope it's like
a mug let's get into this dish here we
go i hope i cooked this fish long enough
i really wasn't paying much attention oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh
yeah hell yes delicious wonderful love
it never lift it oh thank you guys so
much for watching if you like this video
give it a thumbs up i guess and thank
you for being here and i'll see you next
time other than that i don't know
okay ginger are you gingering you sound
like it it's making a lot of noise
classic ginger